the cop just told
me what the do you
mean they cannot resuscitate him that's
what the I mean So eventually she
unscrewed the top and threw it to the
ground and walked up on the porch and
under the rope and started dumping the
gas on report so instantly it's like
okay this is not good hey do you need an
ambulance no huh a father charged with
the murder of his emaciated 8-year-old
son an attempted arson on the birth home
of Martin Luther King Jr and a Florida
city manager who appears to have
drunkenly crashed his bicycle we're
taking a look at the top body cam
moments from Coast to Coast with the
most shocking and compelling video out
there you don't you don't even see
what's going come this house he looks
like he's not eaten in a month we begin
in Poria Illinois with the death of
8-year-old Navan Jones who was found
unresponsive on March 29th of last year
his father Brandon Walker is now charged
with his murder the trial is expected to
begin on Monday the boy's mother
Stephanie Jones already pleaded guilty
to murder charges last week she now
faces at least 20 years in prison and
will likely testify against Walker so
long story short uh last night 8:00 p.m.
kid was put to bed by Mom she gets she's
been up no one checked on him since she
called like two whenever this came in
two whatever she called for him didn't
hear from him went upstairs didn't hear
from went in his room unresponsive cold
she puts him in the bathtub because he's
cold maybe it calls us um as body camera
video explains First Responders arrived
to the Poria home last year to find the
8-year-old boy unresponsive Authorities
on the scene can be heard saying there
has been custody issues with this family
in the past he was last seen at 8 p.m.
when he went to bed she's been up for a
while uh dad left at 6:00 a.m. didn't
check on him took the other son to work
with him she went to go check on him a
little bit ago before she called called
for him he didn't she been gone all day
no she's been here I'm sorry she's been
here but he's just been in a bedroom or
something yeah okay she called for him
didn't hear anything so she went to go
check on him went in the room he was
unresponsive cold to the touch so
because he was cold she went the
bath the guy the blue sht and his
coworker who came with Dad their other
son lives here as well but Dad took the
other son to work with him and he still
at work to my understanding I hav't
confirmed that um Jake and I had a
standby with them and uh dad's mom last
year
or and she went on vacation for a couple
weeks well the kids with them came back
to get the kids it was some dispute of
we've had them you haven't been here
blah has a report and documented all
that she's trying to tell me today that
Grandma wanted nothing to do with the
kids but that's not the case I know
amongst themselves investigators note
the boy is wildly malnourished is there
any anything that looks
suspicious NES at first authorities say
they find a pulse on the boy they're
going to transport
him
um can I get you a code or
anything
okay they're going to transport they
have a they have a pulse but soon
they're unable to resuscitate naen body
camera video captures the devastating
moment when officials break the news to
the boy's parents ma'am I'm sorry just
have to tell you but through all our
effort there's nothing that we can move
further okay oh my
God the cop just told
me what the do you
mean they cannot resuscitate him that's
what the I
mean there's no
way there's no way
I've been telling you and the DCFS
that he needed to be seen you guys are
putting all your business out in front
of everybody that his behavior was not
normal if convicted in his son's death
Brandon Walker could spend the rest of
his life Behind Bars Stephanie Jones is
set to be sentenced in February
switching now to Rhode Island where a
Florida man now faces more than 100
charges for taking police on a
high-speed chase after he opened fire at
a Providence home when he was finally
arrested First Responders found him with
more than 1,000 rounds of
ammunition
almost on December 1st investigators say
43-year-old Joshua pvo began shooting at
a home on the east side of Providence
when police arrived a car chase began
SUV
please all right that vehicle is wanted
and other crimes down there as well body
camera video shows authorities catch up
with
[Music]
Pavo
he's then placed in the back of a squad
car
almost we got
getbody in all Pavo faces 106 counts
including obstructing an officer eluding
an officer with a motor vehicle in a
high-speed Pursuit and carrying a gun
without a permit while pava was arrested
in New England he lives in CMI Florida
about 3 hours south of Fernandina Beach
where a city manager found himself in
hot water how you doing how you doing
sir what's up B everything all right
yeah video shows Ty Ros on the side of
the road all smiles next to a crashed
bicycle what's going on let's get it
what's going on tonight I
am CH okay we're going let you take
taking a sound when asked whether he
lives there Ross can be heard saying
unfortunately do you live here or you on
vacation yeah I I I unfortunately live
here I'm when asked if he's been
drinking Ross Dodges the question G
drinking
tonight it's all right if F I'm just
trying to get you
home it's a real deal an onlooking
couple explained to the officer what
they witnessed what was he doing pardon
what was he doing he was laying in the I
thought he got hit he was laying in the
grass all we did was ride our scooter by
him and turn around and told y'all CU if
he was he got hit I didn't want to touch
him you know so but I went up and talk
to him
that in itself's okay but being in the
road is not okay but soon the officer
loads Ross and his bike into the squad
and they make their way
home all
right have a good night all right thank
you I appreciate your help yeah no
problem just heads up if you ever need a
ride or whatever give us a call we'll
try to get you home okay so that way you
don't fall off on your bike and possibly
get hit by a car okay cuz that wouldn't
be good that's not good no call us
anytime okay thank you you're welcome
have a good night Ross later apologized
at a city commission meeting saying he
thought it would be more responsible to
drunkenly ride his bike rather than
drive a car he was not charged but
Lanisha Henderson does face charges for
attempting to burn down the birth home
of Martin Luther King Jr what are you
doing what are you doing
so she came back down she dumped the she
dropped the can in the bushes and then
came back down to grab her the story
made national headlines when the
26-year-old was caught pouring gasoline
on King's one-time home in Atlanta two
retired NYPD officers and tourists from
Utah rushed to stop Henderson and
detained her as they waited for First
Responders to
arrive
she came up behind us had a gas Canon
and it first she just seemed like she
was kind of doing her thing like thought
she was watering just happened to be
using a gas can to water the plants and
then she had trouble getting it open So
eventually she unscrewed the top and
threw it to the ground and walked up on
the porch and under the rope and started
dumping the gas over porch so instantly
it's like okay this is not good and I
said what are you doing what are you
doing you smell yes so she came back
down she dumped
she dropped the can in the bushes and
then came back down to grab her Lighter
video shows officers cuff Henderson and
walk her off to a squad
car hey ma'am you all
right want to be checked out by gry or
something you know your name
M honey I'm that the leave all
over Henderson is now charged with arson
and is being held in jail without bond
for all the latest body camera videos
True Crime developments and news from
the courtroom make sure to subscribe to
La crime Network's YouTube page
reporting for La crime Network I'm
Sierra Gillespie